THIS COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WILL COME TO ORDER- GOOD MORNING
AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN REST THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WORK ON THE PUBLIC.
AND PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH IN
PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE
BRITISH PATIENT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMING VIA
TELECONFERENCE TO RISK THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON SCREEN AND I WILL
ALSO ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE FOUR FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR ZERO.
OBVIOUSLY ON MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE- STREET BUILDING
I'LL ASK FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THE PRESIDENT ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM. AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING WE HAVE FORTY THREE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA AND ALL
THE MEASURES ARE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS INFORMED US THAT THE
NET THEY DO NOT HAVE FILES FOR
ANY OF THE BILLS WERE HEARING.
AND THE REPRESENTATIVE WILL NOT
BE PARTICIPATING TODAY BEFORE WE
TAKE TESTIMONY ON THE BILLS I'M
GOING TO ESTABLISH A CORPSMAN
WERE MISSING ONE MORE MEMBER
CELL MEMBERS COME ON DOWN SO.
WILL BRIEFLY. HOLD AND THEN
WILL- WHY A COUPLE MINUTES FOR A
QUORUM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CENTER
PORTANTINO. WE'RE CALLING A
QUORUM I'M HERE- FORTINO HERE
SENATOR BATES SENATOR BRADFORD
HERE PERCENTER BRADFORD HERE
SENATOR JONES SENATOR KAMLAGER.
UNDER LAYERED HERE INTERLAYER
HERE CENTER WHITE HOUSE HERE
CASKEY HERE WE HAVE FOUR MEMBERS
PRESENT SO WE HAVE A QUORUM-
WILL MOVE ON TO THE BUSINESS OF
THE DAY DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH AND HEARING
AND TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
AND- CLEANING PROTOCOLS I
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO INSTITUTE A
TIME LIMIT ON WITNESS TESTIMONY.
SHOULD THIS BE NECESSARY EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED FIVE
MINUTES OF TOTAL TIME FOR
PRIMARY TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE WHICH WE COMMONLY CALL
ME TOO. IF NECESSARY WE WILL
ALSO LIMIT ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
TO TEN MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE AS
A REMINDER ALL WITNESSES SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE
PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL
WE'RE NOT GOING TO RE LITIGATE
THE POLICY HERE THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE. SO PLEASE REFRAIN
FROM GOING DOWN THAT ROAD- I
WILL ENFORCE THE ME TOO
PROVISIONS FOR ALL THOSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY WE'RE GONNA GO RIGHT
TO OUR FIRST BILL WHICH IS S. B.
EIGHT FORTY THREE BY SENATOR
GLAZER ON TAXATION THE BILL LET-
SOME OF US HAVE HEARD ABOUT
CALLED THE RENTER'S TAX CREDIT-
SENATOR IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
SENATOR GLAZER HAS. WAY
PRESENTATION SO WE'LL MOVE RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY SURE ANYONE
IN A ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT FORTY THREE. SEE NO
ONE TO THE MICRO- MORE GO TO
MODERATOR MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'D
LIKE TO STAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FORTY THREE OF PLEASE
PRESS STAR FOLLOWED. I WANT ONE
FIVE EIGHT ZERO EXCUSE ME ONE
FILED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
EIGHTEEN YEAH WE WILL QUICKLY
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER ON A PLAN
IN PLACE YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE.
GET TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
MOMENT WE DO A ONE QUEUING UP.
EVERYBODY ELSE IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF FOR SB.
FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND OUR FIRST
. WITNESSES WIND EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TRYING TO
MERGE MY ONE FROM THE OPEN
MARKET WHERE ON BEHALF OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IS THE FOR THE HERO
. AS A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT FORTY THREE
. AND NOBODY IS KEEPING UP WITH
THIS FACT ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT FORTY THREE. SEEING NO
RUSH TO THE MICROPHONE I WILL GO
TO BACK TO THE PHONE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSE STATE FORTY THREE. HE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO SB FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE PUBLIC
ZERO. I NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS NOT PARTICIPATING
TODAY SO COMMITTEE. SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT FORTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. LIVING ON SB NINE
ELEVEN ALSO BY SENATOR GLAZER ON
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD TO FUND
PUBLIC INTEREST MEDIA. SB NINE
ELEVEN THE AUTHORS WAVE SYSTEM-
WAY PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL GO RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
ELEVEN- IS ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
IN SUPPORT OF NINE ELEVEN C. NO
ONE COME TO THE MICROPHONE WILL
GO TO THE MODERATOR MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE ELEVEN. TO-
WORK FOR SB NINE ELEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO FOR
SUPPORT FOR SB. FIVE ELEVEN.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MR CARE ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION TO
THE SP NINE ELEVEN IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
OPPOSED TO NINE ELEVEN C. NO ONE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE WILL GO
RIGHT TO THE MODERATOR
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES. OPPOSED TO SB NINE
ELEVEN. YOUR POST AS THE NINE
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND NOBODY IS GIVING
UP ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE ELEVEN-
AGAIN THERE'S NO FILE SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE ELEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
LIVING ON S. B. NINE TWENTY FOUR
ALSO BY SENATOR GLAZER ON SCHOOL
DISTRICT ANNUAL COMPENSATION
REPORTING. IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAVED
PRESENTATION FOR THE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL GO TO ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM COMING IN THE
MICROPHONE. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF NINE TWENTY FIVE FOUR
SEE NO ONE COME UP. MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE TWENTY
FOUR. HE WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
FIND SUPPORT FOR SB NINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO.
CHERYL IS KILLING US ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE TWENTY FOURS OR ANYONE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED OPPOSED TO
NINE TWENTY FOUR. SEEING NO ONE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO NINE TWENTY FOUR
. IF YOU WOULD LIKE. TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE DO HAVE ONE.
GIVING UP. THERE WAS AN OPERATOR. THE READY ALSO HE WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
TWENTY FOUR CO ES DE ONE ZERO
THIS TIMELY TWENTY TWO YOUR OPEN
. FEDERAL ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FORUM PLEASE
EXPROPRIATION OF. MR HERE NOBODY
ELSE IS QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF NINE TWENTY FOUR
FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE WILL
COME BACK- COMMITTEE THERE'S NO
ARMS GOING UP SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. NINE TWENTY FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
NINE THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR
GLAZERS. CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS FORESTRY TRAINING CENTER
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT I SEE MR MCHALE IS
HERE ON S. B. NINE THIRTY SIX
YEAH YES GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER
KELLY ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY IS
HAVING A TRAINING CENTER IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IS VERY
IMPORTANT LABOR SHORTAGES. ARE
THAT SOMETHING HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED IN ORDER TO HELP US
ADDESS FORCE MANAGEMENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR CHRIS ROSE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH FOREST IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. GREAT SEEING NO ONE ELSE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE WILL GO
TO THE PHONES UP THERE YOU GO.
COME ON OF. HELLO MY NAME IS
OSCAR SORIA FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY- WHAT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU THE-
FOR MANY MINUTES FROM CASTRO
VALLEY HANAE. THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THERE YOU GO
SEEING NO ONE ELSE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO A
MODERATOR ON THE PHONE LINE IS
OR ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE THIRTY SIX. TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE THIRTY CISCO
EIGHT EIGHT ONE FIVE BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY'S GIVING UP ON THE PHONE
LINES THIS YEAR ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION NOW IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
OPPOSED TO NINE THIRTY SIX
SEEING NOBODY HERE. MODDERS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB NINE THIRTY SIX. YOUR OPPOSED
TO SB NINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHTS WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AND NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE THIRTY
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON THIS BE FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE
BY SENATOR GLAZER ON CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION FOR THE RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. WATER IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WHO WAS
SUPPORTIVE OF FOURTEEN THIRTY
NINE. TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN
FALL BY ZERO. NOBODY IS GIVING
UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT LOOK
AT OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN THIRTY
NINE ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM KNOW
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATE
TURNING ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
NINE. WHO ARE ACTUAL OPPOSITION
TO SB FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE
PLEASE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY IN
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE DO HAVE ONE QUEUING UP WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT THE
STRUCTURE PLEASE.
N. Y. FIFTEEN YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTEEN
DEMOCRAT YOU'RE- CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW. OKAY
THANK WITH UNITED- IN THE EMPIRE
. I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT
FOURTEEN NINE SEVEN CALL THAT
KIND IF YOU. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP MR CARE. ALL RIGHT.
OUR THAT WAS THAT WAS OPPOSITION
SO WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN THIRTY
NINE SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WILL MOVE ON TO SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR GLAZER
ON THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR- THIS IS
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION AND
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED NOBODY'S
COMING TO THE MICROPHONES SO
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE IS OR ANYONE IS SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE. TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FOUR BY ZERO. BUT
WHAT HE'S KILLING UP THE
STRUCTURE. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
OFFICE FOR YOUR OPPOSED TO. SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE. HELLO OF
OSCAR SORIANO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU OSCAR
. WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE NOW
ON SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
ANYBODY OPPOSED. HE WOULD LIKE
TO A PRESS OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE FIFTY
THREE A PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND MISTER CERVICAL LINE
TWENTY ONE YOUR OPEN. I AM
ACTUALLY CALLING IN AND SUPPORT
I AM. WITH THAT Q. ADMITTEDLY
THE CON ON BEHALF OF THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
IN SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU. AND THE FINAL
REMINDER OUT TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE SING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SENATOR NEWMAN'S EIGHT FIVE FIVE
CHILDHOOD DROWNING DATA
COLLECTION PILOT PROGRAM. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. WE'LL
GO TO ASPEN IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
HUNDRED SHOW BUT HERE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES MODERATORS OR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
FIVE FIVE. I TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO ONE FALL BY ZERO. OKAY. POLICE GIVING UP HERE ALL
RIGHT WHAT OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
FIVE FIVE SEVEN ONE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED OPPOSED SB EIGHT
FIVE FIVE SEEING NO ONE HERE
MODERATE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE IS OR ANYONE OPPOSED EIGHT
FIVE FIVE. YOU ARE OPPOSED TO SB
EIGHT FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. NOBODY'S QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT FIVE FIVE ABOUT A
SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON THE SENATOR
RUBIO SP EIGHT SIX ZERO ON
PERSONAL INCOME TAX LAW YOUNG
CHILDHOOD TAX CREDIT TO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. MINORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY. SO SUPPORT FOR SB
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED
BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS GOING UP.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO S. B. EIGHT SIXTY.
COME TELL US WHO YOU ARE AND
YOUR POSITION OSKAR'S SORIANO
AND MY POSITION IS I'M A WORKER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MANY MEN AS HAS TO
OUR I THINK THAT IF I THINK-
TAXES THE- ALL RIGHT. WE'VE
HEARD IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
OF S. B. EIGHT SIXTY. A NO HANDS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT SIXTY WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO S. B.
TEN EIGHTY ONE BY SENATOR RUBIO
ON DISORDERLY CONDUCT THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
TWENTY ONE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED IT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN EIGHTY
ONE. THING NO ONE HERE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF TEN
EIGHTY ONE. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR SB TEN
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE MOMENT DISTRICT AREA
WON WITH AN OPERATOR. TO BE WITH
HIS FORMATIVE EARLY THANK YOU.
HE EVERYBODY ELSE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
SB TEN EIGHTY ONE PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX MISTER
KERR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CAN TELL STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
IN THAT REPORT. NOBODY ELSE IS
CUTE ATMOSPHERE ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO OPPOSITION OF TEN
EIGHTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN A OPPOSITION
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO S. B. TEN
EIGHTY ONE. YOUR POST SB TEN
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP THIS YEAR
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO HAS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN EIGHTY ONE. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO S. B. EIGHT SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR LIMON ON DEMENTIA CARE
NAVIGATORS. THIS IS SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. WE DO HAVE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY ONE. CHRIS ROSA ON
BEHALF OF BIOGEN IN SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE CARMANAH.
BUSKER SORIANO NO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. MANY MINNESOTA
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU SEE
NO ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT SIX ONE. YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY ONE. TO
THIRTY POINT ZERO. MY NINETEEN
YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING-
TURMERIC ON COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET FOR ON BEHALF OF IF YOU
DON'T COUNTY IMPORT THANK YOU.
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TWO- SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT SIXTY ONE.
NOBODY ELSE IS GOING UP THIS
YEAR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT SIXTY ONE
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SP EIGHT
SIX ONE. YOUR POST- SB EIGHT
SIXTY ONE PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL
BY ZERO. NOBODY IS GOING UP THIS
YEAR. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
SIXTY ONE. THERE'S NO HANDS
GOING UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT SIXTY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO SB NINE
FIVE TWO BY SENATE ALONE ON
PUPIL INSTRUCTION TO LANGUAGE
PROGRAMS. MODERATE TO ME THEY-
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FIFTY TWO. COME ON UP. OSCAR SORIANO I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MANY METERS IN A SUPPORT
THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE
ELSE COMING UP IN THIS ROOM WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE MODERATE IS
OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF NINE
FIFTY TWO. YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY
ZERO. I NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
ISSUES HERE ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO OPPOSITION TO THE SP NINE
FIFTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED COME INTO THE
MICROPHONE SO MODERATOR PLEASE
GO TO THE PHONE LINE. FOR
OPPOSITION TO NINE FIFTY TWO.
YOUR POST- SB NINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS
GIVING UP THE STRUCTURE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AND NO HANDS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB NINE FIFTY TWO. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSEFUL LEVINE SP NINE SIXTY
SIX ALSO BY SENATOR RAMON
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS AND RURAL HEALTH CLINICS
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO PRESENT- TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE. MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. NINE SIX SIX. YOUR SUPPORT OF
THAT THE UNITED SIX. THE FIRST
ONE ZERO ONE VOEPEL ZERO. W.
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION OF
NINE SIXTY SIX IS THERE ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB NINE
SIXTY SIX COME ON UP JOHN. OSCAR
SORIANO PUTS HIS BILL. ANIMATORS
AND OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
SEE NO ONE ELSE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO NINE SIXTY SIX. IF
YOU ARE OPPOSED TO SB NINE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO ONE
FIVE EIGHT ZERO. NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP THE STRUCTURE. ALL
RIGHT HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES AND
SEEING NO HANDS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB
NINE SIXTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB ELEVEN
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR RAMON. ON
PUBLIC POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
EXEMPTIONS FROM PAY RENT PAYMENT
OF NON RESIDENT TUITION. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
FORTY ONE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. GO TO THE
MICROPHONES AND NO ONE'S HERE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE- SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
FORTY ONE. YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO WE
ARE HAVING FEW PEOPLE QUEUE UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THEY SHOULD
DO IT MORE BOLLINGER MISTER ONCE
. TO GET THE LINE UP. EVERYBODY
ELSE AL GO AWAY FILED ZERO.
ASSIGNED TO WORK FOR A FOR ONE.
AND WILL BE TO FIND FIVE YEAR
OLD. PHOTO MY NAME IS ALEX NILES
I SERVICES SHARED GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE U. STUDENTS OF
PATIENTS ALEX CALLED STRONG
SUPPORT BESSIE LOVE FORTY ONE
FOCUSED UNIT UC SANTA BARBARA
THANKS GO GAUCHOS. THE FIRST
YEAR. NIKOLAI TWENTY YOUR- HELLO
MY NAME IS MARK HELLO MY NAME IS
MARTY I CAN MANAGE AND I AND I
SERVICE THE CAMPUS ACTION
COMMITTEE TACTIC CHAIR OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION I'M A
STUDENT FROM UC SANTA BARBARA
AND I'M CALLING TO VOICE MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR. THE ONE ONE
FOUR ONE THANK YOU THE
CHARACTERS ARE IN THE HOUSE. M.
AS A FIVE REMINDER PRESS ONE
ZERO TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR- SB
ELEVEN FORTY ONE AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MINING I
PRODUCT. THAT WILL BE ON I MET
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING POLITICAL
PLAN THINK THE THEOLOGY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA I ALSO. PRESIDENT OF UT
STUDENT POPULATION AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
FORTY ONE I HAVE TO COME FROM A
MAKE FIVE FAMILY WHERE A BILL
LIKE THAT. WOULD BE INSTRUMENTAL
MAKING COLLEGE MORE A COUPLE OF.
FOR MANY STUDENTS AGAIN I'M HERE
TO REITERATE BUYING REPORTER THE
FELLOW AND I BELIEVE IT IS
NOTHING BUT WE POP IT ANY MORE A
- WILL BE. NOBODY ELSE QUEUED UP
AT THE SITE. ALL RIGHT WE GOT
OFF. OF S. B. ELEVEN FOR ONE.
COME ON UP. OSCAR SORRY AND ON A
BILL. MANY INNOCENT ALSO POSES
NO. ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM OPPOSED S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY ONE MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION OF
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY ONE. YOU ARE
POSED TO US FEELING FORTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE VOEPEL
ZERO. AND NOBODY'S GIVING UP ON
THE PHONE LINES THIS YEAR ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SPLM FORTY ONE
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SPLM FORTY ONE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB 1295%
OF THE LOAN ON OIL AND GAS
HAZARDOUS DESERTED WELLS THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION SO WE'LL GO TO.
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE NINETY FIVE C. NOBODY
COME TO THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE NINETY
FIVE. YOUR SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I THOUGHT BY
ZERO. FIVE NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION S. B. TWELVE
NINETY FIVE COME ON UP GENTLEMAN. OSCAR SORIANA POSE THIS BILL.
MANY MEN AS AN OPPOSE THIS BILL
ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE COME
UP THE MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE NINETY FIVE. YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWELVE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE FALL BY ZERO. I AM SURE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FOR WE DO NOT
WANT QUEUED UP WITH AN OPERATOR
ANYBODY ELSE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. YOU ARE OPPOSED TO
TWELVE NINETY FIVE. HELLO LINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR OPEN. BY EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD. ALL
THE EUROBOND THE AFTER THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE ONE OF THOSE
POSITION HONESTLY TWELVE NINE
FIVE. NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP MISTER CHARICE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION IN SINGLE QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE NINETY FIVE
WILL GO TO SUSPEND. SENATOR
LEYVA HAS SB EIGHT SIX NINE ON
HOUSING MOBILE HOME PARKS
RECREATIONAL VEHICLE PARKS
MANAGER TRAINING IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL GO RIGHT
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF ROOM
NEXT TO ME OF EIGHT SIXTY NINE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHT SIX NINE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SIXTY NINE
COLLEGIATE ONE FILED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FALL BY ZERO
PLEASE. SOMEBODY IS GOING UP THE
STRUCTURE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE OPPOSED
EIGHT SIXTY NINE SEEING NO ONE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE. FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT SIXTY
NINE. YOUR IN OPPOSITION TO.
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED BY
ZERO. YOU'RE I OPPOSITION TO SB
SIXTY NINE. MISTER CHAIR TO HAVE
ONE WITH US MOMENTARILY. NOBODY
ELSE GOING AT ONE ZERO YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY YOUR OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR CHRIS
WHY SAKE WITH WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING COMMUNITIES
ASSOCIATION AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. BUT WHAT ELSE
IS CUTER MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHTS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT SIXTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
SB EIGHT SEVENTY BY PORTANTINO
AND DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. I
HAVE WAY PRESENTATION IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND WILL GO
TO TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. COMMA FOSTER
SORIANO AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU OSCAR.
TWENTY MINUTES AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU MANAGED. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE EXHAUSTED ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SEVENTY.
YOUR ORDER THAT'S THE EIGHT
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY'S COMING OUT THIS
YEAR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO SP EIGHT
SEVENTY. GARBO'S SB EIGHT
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FALL BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE COMPANY
ALREADY QUEUING UP MR HERE.
RIGHT THANK YOU- WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION- MY COLLEAGUE
TO THE RIGHT TO- AS A GOOD JOKE
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT SACKED WHO VOTED SUSPENSE
MOVIE AT S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
BY SENATOR DODD IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE HE'S WAY PRESENTATION
IT'S ON PHARMACIES MOBILE UNITS
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WHO S SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN TO SEE NO ONE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT SEVEN TWO. YOUR
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
ONE FALL BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP THE STREET HERE ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED OPPOSE STATE SEVENTY TWO
COME ON UP GENTLEMAN. OSKAR'S
SORIANO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MANY MEAN AS AN AYE OPPOSED THIS
BILL. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR MORE OPPOSITION
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO MODERATOR. IF
YOUR POST SB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
CALL EIGHT ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO
IF THIS TIME. SPAN LINE NINETEEN
EUROPE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS I ACTUALLY
WAS CALLING IN SUPPORT MODELING
COOPER NELSON LOOKS FAR ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO. THE HEELS. AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO OUR SB SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO WE HAVE NO WAY TO PARTISAN
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO SEEING NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION. EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
CHEVELLE TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
TO SENATOR PACKERS EIGHT SEVEN
SIX ON EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY.
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
TO ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. THERE'S
NO ONE RUSHING TO THE
MICROPHONES TESTIFIED SUPPORT OF
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX- YOU CAN COME
ON A- THE- OSCAR SORIANA NICE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ENJAMIN IS
NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF. EIGHT
SEVEN SIX. YOUR IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO ONE FALL BY ZERO. I
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP THE
STRUCTURE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION AT EIGHT SEVEN SIX IS
THERE ANYONE A ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED OPPOSE STATE SEVENTY SIX
THERE'S NO ONE HERE. MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SEVEN SIX. IF
YOU ARE POSTED SB EIGHT SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE
FIVE BY ZERO. IT WILL BE QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION. AND WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT SEVEN SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
THE S. B. EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN BY
SENATOR PACKER ON ELECTRICITY
TRANSMISSION FACILITY PLANNING.
TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
TO ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. THERE'S
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM WHO'S COMING
TO THE MICROPHONE SUPPORT OF
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN SOME MODERATE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
SUPPORT OF EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN.
VIEW SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. POINT ALL BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NOBODY IS GIVING UP ITS
FAIR. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK
TO THE ROOM FOR OPPOSITION TO
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN. COME ON UP
GENTLEMAN. OSCAR SORIANO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MENINO'S
NASSER UNLESS FIFTH. THE
PROPOSAL HELLO ALL RIGHT WE GOT
IT. LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR OPPOSITION EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN. YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SP EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN
FILED BY ZERO. AND NOBODY'S
KEEPING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION ENCINO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPEND.
MOVING ON SB NINE FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PACKER ON HOUSING
FINANCE PROGRAMS. DEVELOPMENT
RESERVES THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHOR IS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THIRTY ONE TWELVE HUNDRED
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE FORTY
EIGHT SEEING NO RUSH TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF NINE FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU I TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHEN FILED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE FORTY. ONE
PARTY SECURED UP WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT THE
STRUCTURE. THE LADY OF. VOID IT
WENT OFF BY ZERO. SO SUPPORT FOR
NINE FORTY EIGHT AND ONE THIRTY
ONE YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOB ALREADY LIVE WITH A
QUICK PROP THAT MEDICARE THAT
THIS KIND OF JOAQUIN FROM
CARTILAGINOUS FISHES CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES AND
SUPPORT OF EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN.
MISTER BECKER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE LAST. GOTTA MOVE
FAST IN THIS COME THE CASE. IT
ADDED. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
SUPPORT OF NINE FORTY EIGHT. THE
PARTICULAR UP AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO OPPOSITION OF NINE FORTY
EIGHT ANYBODY IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED OPPOSED TO S. B. NINE
FORTY EIGHTEEN NO ONE COME TO
THE MIKE FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO NINE FORTY
EIGHT. YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO SB
NINE FORTY EIGHT CALL EIGHT
EIGHT ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
FILED BY ZERO. NOBODY'S QUEUING
UP THE STRUCTURE ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND HAVING NO FILE AND NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE FORTY EIGHT. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE. GENERAL ROTH HAS SB
EIGHT EIGHT THREE ON UMBILICAL
CORD BLOOD COLLECTION. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHT THREE
. GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
. IF YOU ARE SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTY THREE. THE START TAKE
THIS UP TO RESET ONE FALL BY
ZERO ONE TALK BY ZERO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT EIGHT THREE
WE WON WITH AN OPERATOR
RESEARCHER. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THE RADIO. GOING ONE FIVE EIGHT
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT
EIGHT THREE.
ALL RIGHT NO SUPPORT FOR BUT WE
DO HAVE ONE WE HAVE WITH THE
OPERATOR IAPOLOGIZE TO SHOULD
BE WITH THIS- APPARENTLY THEY'RE
NOT RESPONDING TO THE OPERATOR
SO. WELL I HAVEN'T MISTER SHARE
SORRY ABOUT THAT ALL RIGHT IF
THEY COME ONLINE WILL LET HIM GO
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED FOR
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHT EIGHT THREE
SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE OPPOSED EIGHT EIGHT
THREE MODERATOR WILL COME BACK
TO YOU FOR OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
EIGHT THREE OR IF THAT PERSON.
GOT IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT WILL
TAKE ON. FIVE TO SHOW OUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO.
WE'RE GETTING ONLY QUEUED UP
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHTS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
EIGHT THREE SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT EIGHT
THREE. FOUR GO TO SUSPENSE
SENATOR LAYER HAS SOME BILLS
BEFORE US STARTING WITH S. B.
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WITH FOSTER YOUTH THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CAN MAKE MY
COLLEAGUES WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE. MY FEAR IS A POOR OF
SB EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FILED BY
ZERO. MISTER AS YOU CAN POSSIBLY
USE MORE MONIES SIX SIX SIX
EIGHT COMMUNITY AND WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUEUEING UP ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. YES WE'LL SEE WHAT
THE. OKAY ON THE CITY. FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- THE FIRST
ONE FILED BY ZERO FOUR AT THIS
TIME AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO WINE
TWENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN ONE
TWENTY THREE. GOOD MORNING JERRY
NUMBERED ENJOYING TO GET
HEARINGS ON BEHALF OF THE ALL
THE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU PIXELBOOK
LINE TWENTY FOR YOUR OFFICE.
HELLO THIS IS JORDAN THE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHTY FIVE. HOWEVER NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION OF EIGHT EIGHT
FIVES OR ANYONE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED OPPOSED EIGHT EIGHT FIVE
. COMMA OSCAR SORIANA POSES BILL. ANY MANNERS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. HI RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN A
POSITION IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHTY
FIVE GOING OF ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE FALL BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP THE
STRIX ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON THE EIGHT NINE FIVE BY
SENATOR LAYERED ON SOLID WASTE
NONPROFIT. CONVENIENCE OWN
RECYCLER. THAT MY COLLEAGUE IS
WAY PRESENTATION IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND WE GO TO TESTIMONY
AND SUPPORT IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED OF EIGHT NINE FIVE. COME
ON UP. OSCA SORIANO NICE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. MISSING SENATORS ARE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT SEE
NO ONE ELSE COME TO SUPPORT WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT
OF EIGHT NINE FIVE THE LION
KING. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT
NINE FIVE ONE ZERO THIS TIME
WHEN FILED ZERO OR. ON THE
ESTABLISHED UP DISAPPEAR. ALL
RIGHT GO DROPPED OF EIGHT NINE.
IS OR ANYONE THIS ROOM OPPOSE
EIGHT NINE FIVE C. KNOWN COME TO
MY FROM MY- ARE ON THE FOR LINE
OPPOSED EIGHT NINE FIVE
ORGANIZATION. IF YOU ARE POSTED
SB. EIGHT NINE FIVE ONE TWO.
WHAT FOLLOWED BY. NOBODY QUEUING
UP. ALL RIGHT WE'VE SUPPORT
OPPOSITE OF EIGHT NINE FIVE. NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. FIFTY EIGHT
NINE FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SENATOR LEHRER HAS TEN SIXTY
EIGHT ON THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CLIMATE CHANGE
ISSUES. MY COLLEAGUES WAVE
PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES AND WE'LL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF TEN
SIXTY EIGHT. SEEING NO ONE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE. FOR
SUPPORT OF TEN SIXTY EIGHT. YOU
ARE IN A SUPPORT OF S. B. KIM
SIXTY EIGHT. EIGHT ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO.
NOBODY'S GIVING UP HIS SHARE.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM WHO'S SUPPOSED TO TEN
SIXTY EIGHT COME ON UP. THE MOVE
. MANY MEN AS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK TO WASTE MONEY.
SCREWWORM LIKE FIXING GAS OR
SOMETHING. OSKAR SORIANO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU OSCAR THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN HE LET HIM GO FIRST. AB
CHEN ALL RIGHT THAT WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE ANYONE ELSE
SUPPOSED TO S. B. TEN SIXTY
EIGHT. YOUR OPPOSED TO SB TEN
SIXTY EIGHT GOING AT ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO. TWO
INSTANCES. NOBODY'S GIVING UP
THE STRIP CARE ALRIGHT HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF TEN
SIXTY EIGHT SEEING NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN SIXTY EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
AND SB ELEVEN FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR LAYERED ON THE
CALIFORNIA GLOBAL WARMING
SOLUTIONS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX. GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
DASHBOARD THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE MY CALLING IS. WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE SEEING NO ONE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
SUPPORT. SB ELEVEN FORTY FIVE.
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE GOING ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO
POLICE. RESKILLING UP IT IS TIME
CERTAIN WILL GO DOWN POSITION OF
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE IF ANYBODY
WANTS TO OPPOSE ELEVEN FORTY
FIVE NOW IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY.
OSCAR'S SORIANO AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT MANY
STAYING IN THE CROWD ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION SPLM FORTY
FIVE. YOU ARE OPPOSED TO SB
ALIVE FORTY FIVE GOING AT ONCE
SOMEBODY'S ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
FILED BY ZERO. NOBODY'S GIVING
UP MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WE
HAVE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION ELEVEN. FORTY
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR LAYERED ON SAFE DRINKING
WATER STATE REVOLVING FUND IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MY
COLLEAGUES WAY PRESENTATIONS.
WILL TESTIMONY AT SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT. COME ON UP
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. OSCAR
SORIANO AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MANY MINUTES MASSPORT
THIS WILL ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONE LINEIS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT. YOUR
SUPPORT OF- SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THE FIRST. ONE ZERO ONE
FIVE EIGHT ZERO. ALWAYS QUEUING
UP MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM COMING TO THE MICROPHONE
OPPOSED ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT. FOR OUR
POST TO- S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
FIVE EIGHT ZERO. THAT CALAVERAS
FUELING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS NO
COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO SB EIGHT
NINETY TWO BY SENATOR HER TADO
ON CYBER SECURITY IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED FOR SUPPORT
OF S. B. EIGHT NINETY TWO. COME
ON UP. OSCAR SORIANO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MANY MINUTES
MASSPORT SPILL CYBER GOBLIN SUCK. IT'S WE WILL MOVE ON TO PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
NINETY TWO. EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR SB NINETY TWO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED
BY ZERO TO EXPRESS SUPPORT. FOR
FIFTY NINETY TWO. GOING UP THE
STREET NO ONE COMING OUT AT
LET'S GO DROP OF S. B. A. NINETY
TWO AND TWELVE HUNDRED. THERE'S
NO COMING IN THE MICRO. WITH TO
THE PHONE LINE. FOR OPPOSITION.
EIGHT NINETY TWO. WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO SB EIGHT NINETY TWO
THESE PRESS. ONE ZERO ONE FIVE
EIGHT ZERO. NOBODY SPEWING OUT
THIS YEAR ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IT
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
NINETY TWO SAYING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
NINETY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
REMEMBER WE HAVE A P. G. OR G.
RATED AUDIENCE. JUST TEASING YOU
ABOUT YOUR LIFE. ALL RIGHT SO
EIGHT NINETY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WILL GO TO SB TEN
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR TODD A ONE
FAMILY FINDING AN ENGAGEMENT TO
THAT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. AND
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TEN NINETY ONE. COME ON UP.
OSCAR SERRANO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MEDIMMUNE IS NOT SUPPORT
HIS FELLOW. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR OTHER
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TEN NINETY ONE- EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR SB TEN NINETY ONE. PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY
ZERO. NOBODY'S QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF TEN NINETY ONE
SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION OF
TEN NINETY ONE. YOUR POST SB TEN
NINETY ONE PRESS ONE ZERO. BUT
WHAT HE'S QUEUING UP THE STRIP
CARE ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
NINETY ONE SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN NINETY
ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE LIVING
ON TO DOCTOR PAN HAS SB NINE
AWAIT STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
ADVISORY COMMISSION THAT DOCTORS
WAY PRESENTATION. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO RIGHT
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF NINE
AWAIT SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE ON SUPPORT OF NINE
AWAIT. YOUR SUPPORT OF SB NINE
OH EIGHT PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO.
NOBODY'S GIVING UP THIS YEAR.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE AWAIT. COME ON A
GENTLEMAN. OSCAR SORIA NON I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT. BENJAMIN IS
NOT STRONGLY OPPOSES. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN THE OPPOSITION IN
THIS ROOM MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
NINE AWAIT. YOU ARE POSTED S. B.
FINALLY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO-
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF NINE AWAIT WE SEE NO
QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB NINE AWAIT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. PULLING ON S. B. NINE
FORTY FOUR DOCTOR PAN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE GOOD
DOCTOR'S WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. TWENTY
ONE IN SUPPORT OF NINE FORTY
FOUR. SEE NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THEPHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
IT SB NINE FOUR FOUR. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT THE ACTUAL
SERGEANTS SUPPORT YEP SORRY
ABOUT THAT- TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB NINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO ONE FIVE FIVE ZERO. AND
NOBODY'S GIVING UP THE SPHERE.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FORTY
FOURS ANYBODY OPPOSED TO NINE
FOUR FOUR. SEE NO ONE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITIONOF SB
NINE FOUR FOUR. YOUR OPPOSED TO
SB NINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED
BY ZERO. NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
THIS YEAR ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF
NINE FOUR FORCING NO QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU SB
NINE FOUR FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB TEN NINETY SEVEN ON
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
DOCTOR'S WAY PRESENTATION. AND
WE WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. THREE YOU
KNOW THERE'S SOME REASON THAT
YOU DO THOSE AND THREE SIDE.
YEAH I HAVE ONE MORE TO GO- SO
WE'LL TAKE SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
FOUR FOUR IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. I'M SURE. YES HELLO I'M
SORRY YOU'RE RIGHT TEN NINETY
SEVEN SUPPORT OF OSCAR SERRANO
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
. MANY MINUTES AND I ALSO
SUPPORT THIS I THINK IT'S PRETTY
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW TO PUT IN
YOUR BODY. FOR ALL RIGHT. ANYONE
ELSE. ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF TEN NINETY SEVEN.
GUARD TO PORT OF SPT NINETY
SEVEN PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE WILL ALIGN TWELVE YOUR UP IF. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERS
SYSTEM BUT THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES
CALLING IN SUPPORT IF YOU.
NOBODY ELSE IS CUTER MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN NINETY
SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM AT THE MICROPHONE.
MODERATORS OR ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION. SB TEN NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
NOBODY ELSE IS GIVING UP. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF TEN NINETY SEVEN I
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN NINETY SEVEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON S.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO BY DR FAN
AND CALIFORNIA PRIVACY RIGHTS OF
ACT THE CALIFORNIA PRIVACY RIGHT
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO SAYING
NOBODY RUSHED TO THE MICROPHONE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
TWO. YOUR SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE FALL BY ZERO. ONE WITH
AN OPERATOR. NOBODY ELSE GOING
HAVE ONE FILED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY
TWO NINE THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REMEMBER
CATALINA SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION'S PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE AND ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE ELEVEN SEVENTY
TWO. THANK YOU. MISTER NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
OF ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO
COME ON UP. OSCAR SERRANO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MENINAS NINE
POSES BILL. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN OPPOSITION ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE IS OR ANYONE OPPOSED TO SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO ON THE PHONE
LINE. YOU ARE OPPOSED TO SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO POINT FALL BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY
ZERO PLEASE. NOBODY'S GOING UP
THE STRUCTURE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB TWELVE
THIRTY FOUR ALSO BY DR PAN ON
FAMILY PLANNING ACCESS CARE AND
TREATMENT. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED- THERE'S NO
ONE COMING TO THE MICROPHONE IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. TWELVE THIRTY FOUR.
MODERATORS DID WE LOSE THE
MODERATOR. WHERE THERE THE CYBER
SECURITY ISSUES. WELCOME TO THE
REST OF MANY WAS RIGHT SEE THAT
MANY THE CYPRESS GUYS GOT AFTER
THE MODERATOR C. IT HAPPENED
RIGHT HERE. BEAR WITH US IF
YOU'RE PAYING OUT IF YOU'RE
WATCHING US FROM HOME. WE LOST
THE MODERATOR. FILE IN THEIR TAX
. IT IS TAX DAY. THE. YOU BANG
ON THE TABLE IT WAS AN
EARTHQUAKE. JUST GOES TO SHOW
YOU SOMETHING ALWAYS CAN KALRA.
CHAOS THEORY JEFF GOLDBLUM.
MAYBE THAT MEANS JURASSIC PARK
IS OUTSIDE. ALL THEIR STUFF
HAPPENING. I DON'T THINK.
I GUESS I GUESS. YEAH. FOUR ONE
TWO. WELL. HOUSE. MACINNES.
QUESTION ON. YEAH. RIGHT RIGHT
SO. TWENTY
ANYONE. YEAH. ALRIGHT. DON'T
HANG UP DON'T HANG UP THAT'S
PARTY ON THE PHONE OKAY. OKAY.
YOU'RE NOT. SHOWN. I THINK- HI.
YEAH.
HAPPY AND THEN. YEAH YEAH. THAT
IS A THAT IS- LEVINE WE'RE. YEAH. PROBABLY WE'RE WORKING YEAH.
FOUR HUNDRED. OKAY. IF YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS AT HOME WHERE
SCREENING OUT THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WITH OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HEAR FROM EVERYONE SO
WE'RE- FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENED
WITH OUR MODERATOR. BEAR WITH US.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
SHORT RECESS AND WILL BE BACK
SHORTLY.
ALL RIGHT WARY HAVE A CONNECTION
. THE COMMITTEE WILL RECONVENE
IN THIRTY SECONDS. HE. BACK ON.
BUT WE GET WE'RE GOOD TO GO
WE'RE BACK IN SESSION. WE LEFT
OFF AND SB TWELVE THIRTY FOUR BY
DR PAN ON FAMILY PLANNING ACCESS
DOCTRINE IS WAY PRESENTATION
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. WE
WILL GO TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
FOR SB TWELVE THIRTY FOUR.
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWELVE THIRTY FOUR
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WHEN FALL BY
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR W. QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOT GO TO
OPPOSITION GROUP OF TWELVE
THIRTY FOUR IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE OPPOSED TO TWELVE
THIRTY FOUR MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED A ROOM
TWELVE THIRTY FOUR. YOUR OPOSED
TO- SB TWELVE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. SURE SURE NOBODY'S GIVING
UP ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF TWELVE
THIRTY FOUR AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE THIRTY FOUR COSTA
SUSPENSE IF YOU WERE BEEN
WATCHING US WE HAD A LITTLE BIT
OF A TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY I
THINK IT'S ALL BEEN. IRONED OUT
SO AGAIN WE WHILE FROM YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENTS IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY PLEASE LOG ON AND-
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO SB NINE
TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR EGGMAN ON
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
DATA COLLECTION THE AUTHORS WAVE
PRESENTATION AND IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WE WILL GO TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
TWENTY NINE. PLEASE LINE UP.
MANY MINUTES AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. OSCAR SORIANO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL ALL RIGHTS
WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT
TESTIMONY ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF NINE
TWENTY NINE. YOU'RE SUPPORT OF
S. B. NINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN
FALL BY ZERO- MISTER CHAIR.
NOBODY IS KILLING COPS USUALLY
WE DO I WON WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT THEY JUST USED UP. TO BE
WITH HIS MOMENTARILY MISTER
CHAIR. THE BODY OUT ENOUGH ARE
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT FOR SB NINE
TWENTY NINE GO IT ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO. M.
LINE THIRTY NINE YOUR OPEN.
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME'S
ALLISON MOREAU I AM WITH ALAMEDA
COUNTY FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR
THE SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL AND I
SUPPORT SB. NINE TWENTY NINE.
HELLO NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP
ON THE PHONE LANCASTER CARE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT LET'S
GO TO OPPOSITION OF NINE TWENTY
NINE IF YOU'RE POSED IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED COME ON UP
NOBODY'S COMING UP MODERATORS OR
ANYONE OPPOSED TO NINE TWENTY
NINE. YOU ARE OPPOSED TO SB NINE
TWENTY NINE THE FIRST ONE ZERO.
NOW NOBODY'S QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE TWENTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WILL MOVE ON TO S. B.
ONE THOUSAND THREE BY SENATOR
EGGMAN ON TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
TRAINING PROGRAM. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
SB ONE THOUSAND THREE COMMON UP
IF YOU SUPPORT ONE THOUSAND
THREE OSCAR SORIA NONE ARE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. MANY
MINISTERS STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU GENTLEMEN NO ONE
ELSE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE THOUSAND
THREE. YOUR SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THOUSAND THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO. NOBODY
SHOWING UP THE STRUCTURE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
SB ONE THOUSAND THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO ONE
THOUSAND THREE. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO SB ONE THOUSAND THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE FALL
BY ZERO. NOBODY FUELING UP THE
STRUCTURE ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE
NO FILE AND WE HAVE NO QUESTION
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ONE
THOUSAND THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB ELEVEN
FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR EGGMAN. ON
FACILITIES FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER CRISIS
DATABASE IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF ELEVEN
FIFTY FORCE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
SINGLE INCOME THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR GO TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR SUPPORT OF ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR
. YOU LIKE TO STILL SUPPORT FOR
SQL FIFTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO- FOR
EXAMPLE NOBODY QUEUEING UP THIS
FRONT SKEWS ME ONCE YOU STOOD UP
AND WILL THE LINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIRTY NINE.
HELLO MY NAME'S ALLISON MOREAU
I'M WITH FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR
THE SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL AND I
SUPPORT S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR-
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE OPPOSED TO ELEVEN
FIFTY FOUR MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR. IF YOU ARE
POSED TO AT ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO ONE FIVE
EIGHT ZERO. NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
THE STRIP CARE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION ELEVEN
FIFTY FOUR WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
FIFTY FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO S. B. NINE FORTY SIX
FROM MY COLLEAGUE MISTER JONES
SENATOR JONES IT'S TRIAL SUPPORT
PAYMENTS. THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWELVE- SB NINE FORTY SIX IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. THERE'S
NOBODY COMING IN THE MICROPHONE
IN SUPPORT OF NINE FORTY SIX
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF NINE FOUR SIX
TWO BILLS. IF YOU'RE A SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO SB
NINE FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP THE STRUCTURE. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
NINE FORTY SIX COME ON A
GENTLEMAN. WELL OSCAR SORIA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. ANY MEANNESS
AND I OPPOSE THIS ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN THE OPPOSITION IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WHO GO TO
ROOM I WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
ANYBODY ELSE SUPPOSED S. B. NINE
FORTY SIX. OPPOSED TO NINE FORTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
THERE'S NO ONE LIKE YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF NINE FORTY SIX
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE FORTY
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. BILLION
SB TEN NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR
DORADO ON AIR QUALITY IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THAT. AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL PRODUCE
TESTIMONY TO PORTMAN TWELVE
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY RUSHING
IN THE MICROPHONE IN SUPPORT OF
TEN NINETY FIVE SO MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE IS
THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF TEN
NINETY FIVE TO ROUTE SO. THE
FOUR FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE TWO ZERO. I
HAVE TO GO TO BE IN P. THERE'S
NO ONE IN HISTORY. THERE'S NO.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE THEIR MODERATOR
NO. IT DOES NO ONE ACU ALL RIGHT
WE GOT OPPOSITION OF TEN NINETY
FIVE IS OR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO TEN NINETY FIVE
SEEING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE ANYONE OPPOSED TO TEN
NINETY FIVE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSITION FOR TEN NINETY FIVE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN NINETY FIVE A
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ONTO SB
ELEVEN FIFTEEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER ON DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL TAKE
SUPPORT TESTIMONY OF. ELEVEN
FIFTEEN. OSCAR SORIANO NICE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MANY MINUTES
ON A SUPPORT THIS BILL. ALL
RIGHT MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
FIFTEEN. ORDER THIS BE OLYMPIC
TEAM PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO ONE
FIVE EIGHT ZERO. AND WE WILL
LINE NINETEEN YEAR OPEN NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER BURKE
FROM THE OFF THE MARKS WERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
. AN EXTRA ROOM TO GO TO ONE
FORTY THE LADY ELSE QUITE IT ONE
ZERO CONFINED REPORT BY FORTY
YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS
MAKE BASICALLY TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF ONE ONE ONE FIVE.
NOBODY ELSE IS CUTER MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN FIFTEEN. AM
TWELVE HUNDRED WHICH YOU OPPOSE
ELEVEN FIFTEEN MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO ELEVEN FIFTEEN. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. FUND FELL BY. ZERO SIX.
PUBLISHED QUEUING UP MR HERE ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
FIFTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON SB TWELVE OH SIX BY
SENATOR SKINNER ON HYDRO
FLUOROCARBON GASES THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION OF A RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE OH SIX. SEEING NO ONE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
OH SIX. YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO. NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF TWELVE OH SIX IS
RUNNING UNOPPOSED. TO TWELVE OH
SIX. OSKAR SORIANO AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MENINAS WHEN I POSE
THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT MODERATE IT
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
OPPOSITION. TO TWELVE OH SIX
ONE. YOUR OPPOSITION TO THE SP
TWELVE OH SIX WE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY A PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND WE DON'T WANT QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT THE STRUCTURE. WHAT ELSE
ARE GOING TO HAVE PRESS ONE FOR
ALL THEY DO IS TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO SB. TWELVE OH SIX
I THIRTY THREE YOUR OFFICE. HE
FIGURED HE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
IT UNLESS AMENDED AND WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US TO. GET TO A MIDDLE
GROUND THANK YOU. WHAT ELSE IS
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE OH SIX I
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB TWELVE SIX FROM
THE FENCE MOVE ON TO S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
KABIRU ON INCOME AND CORPORATE
TAXES CREDITS WORK OPPORTUNITY
CREDIT. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO TEST MONEY AND SUPPORT IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. THERE'S
NOBODY COMING TO THE MICROPHONE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB THIRTY FORTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO. NOW WE
HAVE ONE CUED UP EVERYBODY ELSE
GOING TO HAVE ONE ZERO TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR- SB. THIRTY
FORTY NINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT EURO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REMEMBER
CATALINA SANCHEZ THE CORBIN PARK
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AB RESEARCHER NOBODY ELSE
IS QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY NINE RIGHT
WE DID BOTH. HELLO SHE JUST WAS
OUT OF SHAPE YEAH ALL RIGHT SO
IF YOU'RE OPPOSE COME ON UP.
THIS IS OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE YES MA'AM UNISON HIGH
DEFINITELY OPPOSES ONE. ALL
RIGHT OSCAR SORIANA NICE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO BACK TO THE PHONE
LINE JUST TO MAKE SURE WE
CAPTURE EVERYBODY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE ON THE PHONE LINE. IF YOUR
POST SB THIRTY FORTY NINE GO
HEAD NO ONE FOLLOWED BY EUROPE
THIS TIME ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO.
W. **** UP THE STRUCTURE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ON THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE I HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY BY SENATOR UMBERG. ON
ELECTIONS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO WE'LL GO TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. I'M SURE
THIRTEEN NO- VISIT I'M ON THE
WRONG BILL STILL ELECTIONS YEAH
THIRTEEN SIXTY HAVE TRACTOR IN
THE PAGE S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
SUPPORT- OSCAR SORIANA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PENNY MENACE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HEARD SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED FOR THIRTEEN
SIXTY MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY. ORDER OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP THE
STRUCTURE ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEEING NOBODY ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN SIXTY. YOU'RE OPPOSED
TO SB THIRTY SIXTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. NOBODY SHOWED UP AT
THE MOMENT THE STRUCTURE. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN SIXTY.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
WILL GO TWO SUSPECTS. MOVING ON
TO OUR FINAL BILL WHICH IS SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
OF TROUBLE BOTH ON BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHOR HAS WAY PRESENTATION AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THIS ROOM FOR
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN. OSCAR SORIANO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MANY
MUNICIPAL SUPPORT THIS BILL ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR FURTHER SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN SEVEN BY CHAU ABOVE. IF
YOU ARE SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE FALL BY ZERO. I AM SURE
NOBODY'S HEALING UP ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
COMING TO THE MICROPHONE OPPOSED
TO FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED
TO SP FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THE
FIRST ONE ZERO. THIS W. QUEUING
UP MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN I SEE NO
QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT OBJECTION%
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE THAT CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA FOR TODAY THERE'S NOTHING
ON CALL THERE WERE NO DO PASSES
EVERYTHING WENT TO SUSPENSE
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
WE VALUE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE INCLUDED BLACK
POLISH ICE FOR THE BRIEF MOMENT
WHERE WE LOST OUR MODERATOR AND
THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S PARTICIPATION
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.